what do Sudoku games wedding seating
plans and assigning frequencies to radio
stations all have in common
they are all related to a well-known
math problem connected to Maps a proof
of this problem was the very first that
relied heavily on a computer this
breakthrough had a huge impact on the
fields of mathematics and computer
science
but it also ignited Decades of debate
about the nature of mathematical proofs
the role of computers in the field and
what it means to be a mathematician
the long and winding Journey started
with a simple question
imagine you had a blank map and you're a
cartographer and you wanted to color the
map so one thing that might be important
is that each region have its own color
and that no two regions that share a
border are the same color and so the
question is how many colors will you
need
it sounds like a simple question how
hard can it be the history surrounding
it is without a doubt one of my favorite
episodes in the history of math one
might think that this problem came from
cartographers but there's really no
evidence that map makers have been
trying to minimize the number of colors
this really came from mathematicians
in 1852 Augustus de Morgan a professor
at University College London brought up
the map coloring problem in a letter to
his friend and the mathematician Sir
William Rowan Hamilton it was de
Morgan's former student Francis Guthrie
who first posed the question Guthrie had
discovered that he could shade in all
the counties in the United Kingdom with
only four colors he wondered if this was
the case for all maps regardless of the
shape size and complexity the Simplicity
of the Four Color theorem that only four
colors are needed to color any map
tantalized mathematicians
however early attempts to prove it
failed 27 years later the first widely
accepted proof came from the British
Barrister Alfred Kemp his proof tackled
the problem by analyzing how countries
connect to each other to understand how
camp and other mathematicians looked at
this problem it helps to strip away all
unnecessary information
we can replace each state by a Vertex a
single point and if two regions neighbor
each other we can draw a line segment
between those two vertices that's called
an edge and so we turn this from a map
coloring problem into a graph coloring
problem can we color the graph with four
or fewer colors so that neighboring
vertices are not the same color
this field of math is known as graph
Theory and it helps mathematicians study
the relationships between objects
converting maps to planar graphs graphs
that can be drawn in a flat plane with
no edges Crossing makes the Four Color
theorem easier to analyze
it turns out that two maps of different
sizes and shapes can be represented by
equivalent planar graphs all that
matters is how the regions are connected
and related to one another focusing on
only the connections within the maps
helped Kemp discover key features that
all maps share
regardless of how complicated all maps
have at least one region that has zero
one two three four or five neighbors
this is known as an unavoidable set
once Kemp had identified an unavoidable
set he set out to prove the Four Color
theorem to understand a surprising step
of his method first assumed that the
theorem is false Kemp's proof is elegant
and clever
suppose we cannot color every map with
four or fewer colors then there must be
a smallest such map if the Four Color
theorem is false there must be a graph
that requires at least five colors this
is known as a minimal counter example
Kemp wanted to show that he could color
this graph with four colors if he could
then a minimal counter example must not
exist in the first place first he found
one vertex in that graph that had five
or fewer neighbors and removed it then
he colored the graph with only four
colors because the graph is smaller than
the minimal counter example
next he put the removed vertex back in
if its neighbors show three or fewer
colors there is a color remaining to
color the vertex
but if the neighbors have all four
colors then there is a problem Kemp then
created a method for recoloring the
graph to free up a color for the
remaining vertex this allowed him to
recolor it with four colors again this
showed that a minimal counter example
the smallest possible graph that needs
five colors doesn't exist that meant the
Four Color theorem must be true
[Music]
unfortunately 11 years later an error
was discovered mathematician Percy
Haywood found that Kemp's recoloring
technique worked when the removed vertex
had four or fewer neighbors but not when
it had five when you read Haywood's
writing you could tell he feels bad for
having discovered this flaw so the
theorem was a conjecture once again
for the next half century mathematicians
continued trying to prove the Four Color
theorem
soon realized that any solution would
require a two-pronged approach first
they needed to expand Kemp's unavoidable
set
this is a collection of configurations
that if you have any graph then one of
these configurations must appear in your
graph the more they looked the bigger
and more complicated these sets became
the second task was to prove that these
configurations were reducible meaning
that if a graph contained one of these
configurations then it could be colored
with four or fewer colors
and proving that these configurations
were reducible also was harder and
harder fortunately by the end of the
1960s and early 70s computers were
becoming faster and more powerful
opening the door to new possibilities
mathematicians realized that some of
this work which was very tedious and
time consuming to do by hand might be
able to be accomplished by the use of
these new computers at this point there
were several teams trying to solve the
Four Color problem using computers
at the University of Illinois Wolfgang
Hawken a well-known topologist teamed up
with Kenneth Appel a mathematics
professor and one of the only people who
knew how to use the University's new
high-powered computers in 1976 after
about six months of work and more than a
thousand hours of computer time they
proved the Four Color theorem Hawking
and Appel found an unavoidable set
consisting of
1936 reducible configurations every map
has to have at least one of these
configurations and any map that does can
be colored with four or fewer colors
far too many for any human or even team
of humans to check by hand
at the time computers were primarily
used to perform mathematical
calculations and not for what was
considered the human endeavor of solving
proofs in theoretical mathematics
as the first major computer assisted
proof the Four Color theorem raised
questions about what actually counts as
a proof some researchers even questioned
the legitimacy of Appel and Hawkins
method
but if we put ourselves back in the
mindset of 1970s mathematicians this
idea that one of the most famous
unsolved problems in history was solved
by over a thousand hours of computer
time that seems sort of anti-climactic
or not playing by the rules these
unstated rules that mathematicians have
some people thought that if a human
couldn't read it from end to end then it
wasn't a legitimate proof
But as time progressed the use of
computers in theoretical mathematics
became more accepted as a younger
generation got older this newfangled
technology just became the way that we
did math and today we're much more
comfortable with it than we were at that
time today mathematicians often use
computers to check proofs of theorems or
even to generate proofs themselves this
fruitful and continuing marriage of
mathematics and computers all started
with a seemingly simple question of how
to color Maps
through the study of this problem
mathematics was created and advanced in
so many ways this was one of the major
drivers of the study of graph Theory or
network Theory the ideas Behind These
theories are now ubiquitous we use
graphs and networks to describe the way
disease spreads and the way computer
networks are connected while the Four
Color theorem might seem like a
mathematical curiosity it really did
push the boundaries of mathematics
forward
[Music]
um